hmmm I understand your lives and in this
video I want to talk to you about the
importance of EPC certificates and EPC
certificate is something that's often
banded around when you're right now
you'll see a little rating next to where
it says EPC and some people are like
wonder if does this mean and why is it
really important so this video is for
you if you ever intend on buying and
owning property to rent out or even to
live in yourself I also got a little
special bonus nugget at the end of the
video so stay tuned until the very end
oh so what does it mean peace is
difficult it stands for energy
performance certificate so it rates how
energy-efficient the house is now an EPC
certificate is going to be marched
somewhere between a and G a means
fantastic G means it's really bad and
typically you're gonna get around about
a D or an e average houses are DNA
EPC snippets were introduced to England
and Wales in 2007 August the 1st and
right now as I'm doing this video every
vital a residential house must have an
EPC certificate and it must be no higher
than an e so if you're about to buy a
house before you buy it
check the EPC if the EPC is more than II
do not buy the house or find out exactly
why it's high and C you can fix it
simply how do you fix it if you've got a
really high EPC it might just be a case
of the boiler needs changing maybe the
new windows are not double glazed and
it's causing the house to run not very
efficiently at all maybe you need a
secondary heating system or maybe it's
just a case of you need to insulate some
of the walls so find out what the
problem is you want to bring that EPC as
low as possible which is going to mean
that your tenants they're going to stay
longer because they're not gonna be
happy to pay a fortune to run the house
and if it's a HMO property or you'll
paying the bills as the landlord then of
course your ex to incentivize to try and
keep it as energy efficient as possible
now you'll need a new EP C certificate
every 10 years by law it costs on
average depending on the house about 100
pounds to get an energy surveyor to go
in and do an EPC certificate and you
want to do that every
ten years now not all buildings will
meet EBT certificates if it's a certain
type of commercial property or if it's a
building that's about to be knocked down
or an unsafe building or a church a
place of worship then it will not need
an EPC certificate but generally
speaking always check this before you
buy any house and I hope this video has
been helpful I did promise there'll be a
little bonus piece of content at the end
and that is on a similar type of story
council tax band before you buy a house
also check the council tax band that's
going to be anywhere between a and H
again same story I means the council tax
each month is going to be really really
really cheap and H means it's going to
be really really really expensive before
you buy a house even if you're not going
to be having to pay the council tax
you should still check it out because
you want to know what to be able to tell
your tenant also if your tenant moves
out you're responsible for paying the
council tax bill while the property is
unoccupied where I live I think council
tax is really high where I live it's
like an H or G might be a G but that
means I have to pay for tuning council
tax so for my rental properties I'll
always try and make sure they're a
roundabout and D a C and you do really
well so hope that helps well I want you
to run a successful property portfolio I
want it also to run as economically as
possible and obviously it has to be
legal so check these things before you
buy a house if you enjoyed this video
smash the like button or smash the
dislike button I don't really care as
long as you do something but please of
course don't forget to subscribe
smash the subscribe button turn on the
notification valve because I'm going to
be doing some really amazing videos over
the coming days and weeks thanks so much
I'll see you next time